seven just rip oh my god i still
remember walking
from a movie her majesty's secret
service with james bond
and making my godfather go to 42nd
street and there was those record stores
and i bought the album abc i didn't give
a [ __ ] what time it was when i got home
i put it on there was no earphones then
there was nothing we just put that
[ __ ] on and let the neighbors
knocked [ __ ] it
what was the first song that came out on
that
i think it was abc oh okay abc and i
want your back is on that and there's
something else on that and then after
that they just [ __ ] it was a wrap
there was no [ __ ] looking back man
and he did that for 30 [ __ ] years
after that so
you know it's it's amazing we were at
the uh ice house one night and mrs pat
was there right and we're talking about
michael jackson now and i said my
favorite michael jackson album of all
time
is the best of michael jackson it was
transition
in between the jackson five and the solo
career oh all right it was like 80 he
still had the nose he still had the afro
and he put out an alum call and it was
him with a pigeon on it and she was
laughing on me she said ain't no michael
jackson with a white [ __ ]
pigeon and bam we found it oh my god
that's my when i look it up it's because
i remember i was best of michael jackson
is he wearing like a black jacket and a
gray shirt
no he's not a raider fan at that point
he's still [ __ ] yeah
he's still jumping up and down with the
indianapolis
colts or whatever the [ __ ] he was into
at that time
yeah the best of michael jackson i got
to be where you are
one day in your life
it's got a bunch of great [ __ ] jams
on there you know it just turns out you
know this is how life turned out to
it's like anderson silva to be the
champion for so long and then a [ __ ]
little steroid thing yeah it's just him
holding like a dove oh dove yeah that's
a [ __ ] best yeah
i still remember all that [ __ ] like i
was a kid when all that was news like
when jermaine left to marry the daughter
like that was [ __ ] groundbreaking
like you know it wasn't on tmz there was
no tmz but i remember them talking about
in the news like for people who don't
know the jackson five were defunct yeah
they're done jermaine left to marry the
[ __ ] thing
and you knew it was gonna it was gonna
be michael time so what do you do
because like now nowadays if like a band
breaks up it goes over twitter like that
like that one dude just left one
direction and like the internet exploded
what happens before the internet like
when that happens still like people just
go they just want you know you heard
about it and if you were a jackson 5 fan
you know by that time that all gotten
older they got ugly they weren't the
cute little [ __ ] kids that came on
the scene but michael could sing yeah he
was the talent of everybody you know he
was jordan of the squad yeah he was
michael jordan jermaine was pippin you
know yeah yeah and then uh but janet
came through janet jackson came through
of all of them at the end she was like
the kobe but you know what's going on
with her now no it's a [ __ ] nightmare
oh yeah her album came out or it's
coming out and they got a world tour
they're not selling tickets oh three
tickets i saw like 12 tickets so they're
trying to play the old janet if you look
i think the album's for free on [ __ ]
youtube oh [ __ ] like yeah you know
listen man you cannot not put an album
for eight years or whatever the [ __ ] she
did and stay yeah vocal in this you know
they could do that [ __ ] yeah but you're
still gonna always have your bass fans
okay but it's a whole new game out there
janet jackson's an old [ __ ] lady now
come here
singing sex songs yeah to be singing
whatever and jumping up and down with
people so that was the thing she made a
heavy transition dog that was a giant i
went to see you i went to see its work
yeah rhythm nation no uh if if
she was [ __ ] smoking
is it possible for her to be good for
that long though like could it just be
that she's had a good run
like jesus listen man when you're an
artist a musician whatever [ __ ] you are
you continue to make music whether
you're you're selling records or you're
not selling records then you have a base
core of fans and they buy whatever the
[ __ ] you put out
they support you they've gone to see you
they support you throughout the years
you know you have a base core of [ __ ]
fans but you gotta
stay current you know i don't know what
the word is what's the word you're
actually acting like you have to stay
she was doing movies for a little bit no
current i think current yeah that's what
you said
yeah you have to stay in like in the
mind of in like pop culture she did a
movie with tupac that was 20 [ __ ]
years ago she let justin timberlake grab
her titty on tv you know with that old
wrinkle [ __ ] brown tail
you know they banned her from cbs yeah i
mean you have to do something in her i
don't know what i heard one song and
it's just too slow janet it's too slow
you gotta [ __ ] pick this [ __ ] up man
yeah i i haven't [ __ ] with janet jackson
since any place anytime would you mind
yeah that's that's if yeah
that's the album [ __ ] [ __ ] if and i'll
tell you what man the pleasure principle
not [ __ ] bad not bad when i was a
beginning comic i had that whatever the
[ __ ] cassette whatever the [ __ ] it was
in the car and i'll tell you what that
proliferation principle got me from
point a
to point b the last album oh and then i
went i said i went to see on if
and then when i moved to la i dated this
girl and she took me to see her at the
[ __ ] coliseum the velvet rope and i
was sitting right next to jimmy schmitz
right
i never met him i never knew nothing i
just sat there he was right next to me
it was like third row her father this
girl's father was the manager of the
stones 20 years ago
something weird
so she got all the tickets i went down
there
i never forget i'm sitting there and
jimmy smits got up bro and he goes hey
you guys need anything
my [ __ ] heart stopped damn my [ __ ]
heart stopped yeah you still remember it
i still [ __ ] sure who does that [ __ ]
who does that
what did you say did you have them get
you something yeah let me get a beer
yeah [ __ ] you since you i was broke how
was this like post la familia because
that's the movie that really this little
amount this is 99 oh yeah
let me tell you something man about
jimmy smithson we've had this
conversation as a matter of fact i was
bored last week after narcos and i went
back
to season six of sons of anarchy from
the beginning
to watch my man jimmy smith just to do a
throwback to watch him play a mexican
first of all let's get something
straight about jimmy smith bro he's been
around for 30 years
oh yeah he was in the pilot of miami
vice he got blown up in the second scene
he was tubbs original [ __ ] he was
crockett's partner
he was the cuban kid that got blown up
in a coke deal first [ __ ] episode
then he has to go into the diner and
tell his wife then he got replaced by
tubs that's how it starts but that's
night that's 31 [ __ ] years ago and
before that there was a spanish dude
that did every piece of work there was
he was the guy that played the spanish
dude and sampling son oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was his name he was the
[ __ ] f he was the spec for 30 years
that guy played a spanish guy that got
insulted by everybody julio julio why
put an episode of julio in this
[ __ ] who your jim ford is saying
julio put samford and son
julio something about puerto rico i
don't want no puerto ricans in my house
wow that that's like that's old [ __ ] i
think i was like five jimmy smits i
respect jimmy smith has had la con la
whatever
then he had another sitcom he had nypd
blue yeah he was on that [ __ ]
for a long time he was on dexter
then he came in as a mexican on [ __ ]
sons of anarchy season six the scene the
pilot oh have you seen that season yet
no i haven't watched the show it opens
up him [ __ ] gemma oh yeah i'm behind
[ __ ] stitched up with gank colors on
and [ __ ] [ __ ] he calls her a cracker
[ __ ] i mean it's yeah julio in the
system watch who this guy is
see this is the julio oh wait this one
below julio was on [ __ ] tv yeah this
is when the sister comes over he don't
like puerto ricans but the sister stays
at the house with them
this is a great [ __ ] episode
i don't know how to go see someone you
will take me please no yes now please no
i gotta finish this work and then i
gotta do some things in the kitchen
please and after that i gotta look in
here and see what dear abby said about
teenage pettin
she got a mustache
okay then get your coat and get your hat
leave your worries on the doors
all right good guys julio's after they
come in oh
yeah they go to the principal school
your mother and mr santa are here why do
you call them i know how to go home we
can't stand your home without a parent
that's jeff garcia
yeah
he simply refuses to go into the fourth
grade he insists he's smarter than a
fourth grader which i have no reason to
doubt
but
well because of the language barry he
can't keep up with the fifth grade why
he says senor sanford he said roberto el
domo
i said the teacher is unable to teach
him
see the principle says el tico is the
demo
but listen if the teacher can't teach
him then she put her back in the fourth
grade
is that real mr sanford most of our
teachers don't speak spanish and the
government won't provide funds to hire
extra teachers who do it's unfortunate
really because
in the younger grades many of our
children are spanish speaking well
that's stupid it's a kid that speaks too
loudly he's smarter than the teacher and
he can also sell lymph
well why does the government provide
funds for this i don't know i imagine
they have other things they consider to
be more important now what's more
important in giving a kid a real good
education
it wasn't all about comedy dawg he was a
bad [ __ ] yeah he spit message
doc put on the episode
with the japanese
say samsung japanese real estate see
what you get see what's your
[ __ ]
you know speaking of old stuff man i was
watching warriors the other day well
they did a reunion in new york or some
[ __ ] yeah
that's crazy
which one
oh no no no yeah yeah home sweet home
home stay home oh my [ __ ] god
home sweet home watch this [ __ ]
episode right here
this is [ __ ] craziness this is when
they want the japanese people
want to offer money what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
put this [ __ ] little clip it over
there
isn't the japanese
wanna buy
his uh property
and he goes to dinner at that house and
[ __ ]
oh it's a full episode oh no they make
them put a robot and [ __ ]
and then they want to sell his property
what's it say pain in the neck
keep going
i just saw it before it don't matter i
don't want to make people sit down [ __ ]
george perez is here we're playing
sampling sons and [ __ ] doctors having
fun brother having fun but it's uh
it's really weird like how those spanish
guys played on tv for a long [ __ ]
time until more it's like bob robert
constanza robert constance is an italian
guy it's been a thousand [ __ ] things
because
for 30 years he was the only new yorker
around here they used them for
everything yeah you know commercials i
mean [ __ ] guy works for a time got a
beautiful [ __ ] house yeah man i got
the same problem with that guy noel he
plays the cholo and everything
noel he was in a bruce almighty fast and
furious
uh training day i haven't seen him
lately yeah he's you know an audition
yeah he's really happy yeah he's cool
he's got he turned christian
yeah he had a little gambling problem
what i heard and now he's doing good
he's doing his thing with the family so
he's not acting anymore i think he is
because uh he was in that one movie the
purge the the last one that's the last
one i've seen him in he's even in video
games
i'm trying to get that cholo nintendo if
you need a troll or call me i'm vintage
you know what i mean you've been banging
it out here for a while george brown
you're like the [ __ ] uh
you're out every night man yeah oh come
on battles you do the roast battles yeah
chief rose battle what'd you just tell
me you did you helped uh what's his name
with the prison special oh yeah uh it
was cool man jeffy ross hit me up and
just you know just uh talked to him give
him ideas and stuff he showed me what he
was doing he was funny in that he was
good i haven't seen that one it was fun
yeah he was good his message was good
yeah he's uh he's a dynamite guy yeah
he's awesome dude and i didn't even know
he gave me a credit and he just goes hey
look at the preview and i was like what
the and my name was under chris rock
that's the first time ever he always
does stuff like that he's taking tony
hensgrove yeah
a lot of writers he gives him a good
chance he's a good [ __ ] dude he comes
out of the store he says things to you
before you go on stage and for a long
time i didn't think i liked him like a
long time i didn't think he liked me and
then uh-huh we started talking he loves
his reefer yeah he loves his
[ __ ] refund he loves writing
good [ __ ] jokes yeah
you've had some great people around you
man but that's [ __ ] cool yeah brother
i'm grinding you know i i had to get out
of that little latin world you know how
that latin word keeps you there like the
ghetto
you know and i was like i know i'm gonna
go explore adventure and i'm meeting
other people and i love it man i love it
one thing about the latin world
which i got to tell you i got a lot of
comedy education oh yes from the comedy
store i'm going to tell you that right
now we talked a lot about the comics so
you people probably your ears are
believing that tommy still again
but the other credit to a lot of my
stage savvy whatever the [ __ ] it is and
presents
is those mexicans oh yeah when i got to
this town man i got spots at the store
but my bread and butter
was rudy moreno was the guys like fly
jeff garcia you
you know felipe and willie have went
tuesday and wednesday
somebody else had thursday you know
on a thursday night you could make you
know 200 bucks in the 60s
and 60s going to different rooms west
kofi and jeff had the safari club oh you
had to walk up 22 [ __ ] steps and the
stage was rattling a bunch of [ __ ]
drug people in there what about casa
latina latino on tuesday tuesday
yeah you can do uh the ice house and
then come over there that's right that's
right i mean those are the days might do
it was so weird to transition because
the transition stopped in 2008
in 2008 we lost 20 [ __ ] rooms in the
city i was like chicago a lot of people
lost rooms and see what happened in no
way
you know that whole stock market thing
that crashed
but that it really affect and this is
what happened i mean
the there was a strike here in 2007 and
it really [ __ ] in 2008 seven yeah it
was like the screen actually right right
screen actors and it really [ __ ] a lot
of people up they wanted that dvd money
or the download some [ __ ] right and i'm
in those days let me tell you something
and i got no reason to lie to no but i
was getting 15 at the store
i was acting a little bit but my bread
and butter were those mexican rooms and
residual checks [ __ ] yeah because my
wife at the time my girlfriend didn't
really know what i made at those rooms
so she said to me where are you going
i'm going to george perez's i was really
going to george perez and somebody else
in lake chino to pick up 80 bucks that
was my cocaine gas and weed money so i'd
still come home with the 50 from george
perez's room
but i'd still have the 80. no i was
going out three nights a week to those
rooms tuesday wednesday thursday come on
bro you're making 150 a week in town if
you hustle if you know how to [ __ ]
step on the gas and tell rudy i'll be
there last i'll close it and you can
balance it there's a laker game this
you know this room is [ __ ] backed up
i mean you could do it stephen
steakhouse thomas casino the [ __ ]
bicycle club we did all those [ __ ]
clubs and i mean to drunk you know i was
there the night that they threw a knife
at darren carter
and i wasn't there he was
well do you know how tommy chen he was
killing on stage and he started talking
to the cholo's girlfriends and they're
like hey we don't we don't let no black
guys talk to girls no no no no no no so
they jumped them but he turned into a
silverback gorilla and just
cause tommy's from detroit
and fly jumped in too
really yeah i wasn't there yeah i wasn't
there that's what i said through a night
where's all the hawaiians at what city
is that by san diego carson no san
diego's got those samoans what's the
ocean side they threw a knife at oh
that's when what's his name rick
martinez oh yeah that's that ocean side
they threw a knife moon doggies or
something no that was in san diego this
is [ __ ] oceanside oh wow then
they had that room that the mexican dude
used to book off of san diego all the
way that was uh
no leonard no no and i'll tell you who
else i used to have tons of comedy when
i moved here the other living i had was
the other direction
the other direction now they're opening
up oxnard the improv yeah open up oxnard
by december yes and that's awesome
really be awesome because there's
nothing up that way so for years lee
wednesday nights was oxnard
tuesdays was bakersfield i remember
going i remember a time and we would try
to make this field for two gigs like one
comic had at eight o'clock and another
comic had a 10 o'clock and they'd say if
you're there for the eight you might as
well come across town and do the 10
o'clock and [ __ ] bakersfield that's
how much the black host up there up
north i don't know in a way what's the
guy that books all up there visalia
and that's papi chulo and the other
london martinez
leonard used to use the black radio guy
oh yeah really cool dude andre covington
drake covington there you go
i'm telling you lee that was so much fun
you know and then i had orange county on
lock remember i had roscoes you know you
would just come for the sandwich
[ __ ] roscoe's has good sandwiches
good sandwiches and let me tell you
something about roscoe's
uh you know i was talking to lee that
how
you even go do comedy somewhere and they
pay you and the room is good but
there's nothing else there yeah you
leave there and you forget about the
room and you go the second time and some
people like hey i'm happy you're here
but there's some rooms you go to
and they give you 30 bucks
but they treat you
like you're [ __ ] adam sandler
and say what you want to say the guy at
roscoe's the guy that used to be a
salesman the big guy yeah dan he was
always good to me oh he's awesome you
understand me yeah you know it's like
the the the dude down in orange county
he don't book a lot of dudes but bro
when you're broke he gives you a dinner
then he goes come here you want dinner
to take home with you when you're a
comic and somebody gives you a
cheeseburger to take home
you remember that for the rest of your
life dog when you're getting fifty
dollars a set in a strange town and the
cook comes over and says come here bro
i'm gonna throw this away you want these
[ __ ] hamburgers and these steak fries
and you're like [ __ ] yeah that dude
what's the comedy magic club
i don't know anyone's counting he always
feeds you and redondo beats down there
he doesn't like me
i'm too dirty for his club oh okay it's
a very white club older people
but that's kind of like isn't it just
good that he tells you that he's like
hey man i was never mad at the guy i
loved the conley magic club because of
that he told me just your comedy doesn't
go over you i got 22 complaints i get it
i'm not mad at you yeah i was too raw
for the room at that time this was like
six years ago
he caters to his neighbors yeah he has
you know jay leno goes there on sundays
to work out yeah
right but
you have a lot of things to say about
like we were talking before about the
people who are in this industry and like
you have a lot of people you always say
people never say no to you they just
don't answer the call
there's a lot of there's probably a lot
of club right there's a lot of people
who won't give you an answer you send
them a tape or you call them and go hey
i got a recommendation from george
president for some reason they just
don't like joe diaz for some reason they
don't like george brooke yeah i get that
too i get it and i don't get my business
it's a part of [ __ ] business and you
know what then you have two things to do
you could take it like a man and
understand you know i don't like hot
dogs you catch up on
right or wrong you like that [ __ ] no i
got just mustard i know but if i'm not
around you'll put ketchup on and mustard
and rub your face like a [ __ ] jamock
i know you
but you know i mean so every
once one man's chicken is another man's
gumbo bro yeah i get it
speaking of which i shot a special this
week oh yeah what'd you do in vegas at
the south point casino 24 years economy
nobody's ever given me [ __ ] i went in
the bank i said [ __ ] it lee let's shoot
it ourselves wow how was the turnout the
turnout was great i gotta listen man uh
as far as the people who listen to this
podcast and the people that we've helped
them they've helped me
i want to thank you i want to give you
my heart you know people showed up
friday night with t-shirts on wow people
showed up saturday night yelling and
screaming and it meant the world to me
it made me
you know work harder and let me you know
this is something i never anticipated
years ago i said something on the rogan
podcast that these people on twitter and
facebook are a bunch of [ __ ] stiffs
and boys i have to eat my words yeah
i've met you know the guy who stole the
weekend was lee obviously
no and the [ __ ] talking layer two
friend a guy that we met from here
that's just a sweetheart he's capping
the security
he's the conciliation of the family but
as far as this little [ __ ] jew
[ __ ]
i was thinking about what that dummy
said to you that night that [ __ ]
idiot that was sitting there that lost
all his clients and everybody fired him
that [ __ ] barry whatever his [ __ ]
name is that came in and tried to be
cute on your expense you know what i'm
saying i've bust your balls but i love
you he was disrespectful that night
he'll never come back i never want to
see that [ __ ] idiot i always thought
he was a [ __ ] idiot anyway but that
night you were stoned you couldn't
really say much and he's like you'll
never be a good manager
oh he knows more about the internet than
any of these [ __ ] managers lee could
walk into three yards and if they were
lucky
if they gave lee 75 000 like they know
what do we do to get our clients on the
internet because anybody knows if you're
on a tv show right now that show's going
to come to an end yes and you want to
hold on to these people that's where the
computer comes in because if not six
years from now you'll be janet jackson
you'll be you know you don't have a
voice in this this internet is where you
need a voice in right now tv shows yeah
you can do a tv show for eight years
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are tell a
story about mugging a hooker and leaving
a [ __ ] cemetery and all some people
start coming to [ __ ] shows so i've
learned a great deal from this podcast
but anybody who came out from this
podcast and supported me friday saturday
and sunday you know me man uh i thank
you with all my heart but at the end of
the day
lee stole the [ __ ] weekend he really
did i give credit where it is high like
i break your balls i do a lot of [ __ ]
because i love you and i gotta tell you
you lifted you
you went farther than what i thought
you'd do you went [ __ ] farther and
beyond man so
without you none of this would be
possible so thank you very much you
stole the [ __ ] weekend and i'm a man
no no way i don't
i tell people how things are and i tell
you both [ __ ] ways george perez we
only got one way to [ __ ] do it you
know yeah straight up hey good [ __ ]
[ __ ] lee take it i know i mean i i
appreciate it's always nice to hear that
but it's just everybody all i want
this [ __ ] kid you know these [ __ ]
managers and agents they think they walk
on the water and they don't know that
part of this [ __ ] luck and the
[ __ ] idiots you know and
part of this [ __ ] after people you see
on comedy center ain't [ __ ] funny you
know after people you see on [ __ ] tv
never make you [ __ ] laugh at your
life and they're making millions of
dollars but that's not the [ __ ] point
their luck is better than our [ __ ]
luck okay we make our luck happen that's
a different you know what i'm never
going to be on netflix netflix don't
like me well i'm not going to give
people a special [ __ ] special five
dollars [ __ ] people [ __ ] hey there's
another oh good [ __ ] times that's
what this is about that's what the
society is about right now you're gonna
lose your [ __ ] job pretty soon you're
going to lose to the japs what the [ __ ]
you're going to lose it too yeah you
better make your own way this is when
your dream kicks into effect and you get
your dream to pay the [ __ ] bills
that's a transition it's getting your
dreams to pay your [ __ ] bills
you know uh i'm really getting out of
the park he really
really hit it out of the park
and uh i could tell it came out good
then so you're [ __ ] it does come out
good and he ran the whole [ __ ] thing
with john salami yeah john killed it
john john isn't here but he
he was really i like
i've been out of for tv production for a
while but this past week was [ __ ] fun
like john just is great
and it was just so much
i see it like whenever i i've worked in
tv or i've been places with you
i see how much
extra stuff is put in and i i do ask
quite i
sometimes ask you stuff just to test the
waters
but i didn't really i don't know what i
did i kind of i just let you do your
thing and
make sure the cameras were on
it was just your behavior before that
that even the flyers the 70 pens from
the dollar store
well [ __ ] we were talking for two
weeks we're gonna do a questionnaire
right man i made up the questionnaire i
emailed him i wanted to see how you were
gonna act on this one this was gonna be
a real test for you
you know we've done the podcast we've
done a documentary we've done two cds
we've done now a special yeah i remember
that cd you did at sal's comedy you
remember that old [ __ ] we never used
that oh [ __ ] never that was terrible
terrible you had but you had a lot of
actors there that day oh we had the dude
there yeah but it was terrible
i couldn't put that out the guy still
calls me he's like i could save it
though there's nothing to say
there is nothing to say that was one of
those calmly a nice dog where you think
you got it
you even have that like [ __ ] yeah just
watch it i didn't watch it
hey but that's good man 10 10 of 2010
that was five [ __ ] years ago i was a
complete different comedian yeah i was
fresh out fresh i was just transitioning
into storytelling a little more and
trying to slow them down i was a
complain i was at a place i had no
[ __ ] idea so you've been out five
years now yeah i've been out five years
man how about parole i'm done i've been
off parole for two years how's it feel
[ __ ] phil white you know i mean
privileged again now for how long were
you in the system the first time the
first time i ever got locked up i think
i did like four months and then there
was still pro how long the probation and
yeah you do that year probation [ __ ]
but then you get a quick job and then
get you off and then the second time i
did a county year eight months
and
after that they give you that little
gang enhancement you know what i'm
saying you get the badge
and uh
yeah we shot a special yes called
whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah right
piazzo and then you got arrested how
long after that once it is well i was i
already got arrested before that special
i was fighting i i got bailed down i was
fighting my case when we did that
special
that's amazing yeah and then like i
think it's like eight months later i get
locked up and then it comes out while
i'm locked up
that was a crazy [ __ ] that the guards
were like i seen you on time last night
and i was just like [ __ ]
i wonder if they're gonna send me money
you know
yeah that was insane man that was insane
but it was good to see you up there i
got to see you in a lot of [ __ ] nobody
believed like i knew you like you don't
know that guy
but it was crazy because i didn't take
that seriously that night
all i wanted that was the night after
thanksgiving yeah i basically shot that
for coke money like i remember they had
an after party i gave my room key to uh
marilyn's husband and i did 90 all the
way home that's the coke guy
i meant crazy i remember we got there
and me and edward showed up and you were
like you i i should have called you guys
they've had me here since seven
this is some boat me and edward i
thought like at 8 30. and you were just
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i want to get out of
here i want to get out of here
that was that was that was fun though
hey we had fun we had a lot of fun we
had fun we killed it that's that's still
really popular like on netflix oh please
when that thing went on
like people were just staring at me they
didn't know what i was saying spanish
people really like that dirty type stuff
no but you gave it up they really don't
they really [ __ ] don't because they
giggle for a couple minutes then the
catholicism comes out it's like the
bible belt once you go to the bible bell
you'll make them giggle for eight
minutes but they're like what the [ __ ]
am i giggling about sex i can't be
laughing at this i go to church every
sunday then you're doomed hey can you
pull up to see what he's wearing though
he's wearing an old-school black sword
with some blue jeans and like something
like i [ __ ] still fight listen listen
though that's all that fit in those days
in those days i used to rotate three
pair of pants two sweatshirts
sneakers and all the big daddy clothing
where i could [ __ ] find wow that's i
spent every time in those days on blow
those last couple years
i lived off big daddy clothing wear
four or five pair of jeans i go to miami
and go to what's that old navy
old navy had 1995 [ __ ] pants for me
the fat man pants
they had the last size i would buy old
navy pants and not wear a belt or buckle
them
and just put the zipper all the way up
because
i could save a ton of [ __ ] money you
have no [ __ ] idea
i went i went there that night thinking
this was not gonna get picked up god
bless i know i'm toyah god bless scott
montoya because i [ __ ] up i let him
down and i've always thought about that
how look at those pants you killed
though you killed i haven't [ __ ]
killed yeah you did
yeah you did
that was [ __ ] embarrassing yeah you
know what's crazy is everybody from that
group did something but me because i got
locked up
i didn't do [ __ ] after that yeah you did
what i do after that and do not now when
did we shoot that 2001. uh
2004
no 2006 really yeah 2006 2006. marilyn
died in 2007.
wow
it came out at 07. but we did so we shot
in those six yeah some ghetto theater
inside [ __ ] years ago yeah
oh my god i was out of control
that was the point i was out of control
he'd call me up hey uncle joey need some
red money let me know when the rooms are
open
yeah that and back then his message on
his voicemail was like don't don't don't
you even dare lit if you ain't got money
in the envelope
or a jew or you're my lawyer
don't leave a second message
i would torment people
i was in such bad [ __ ] shape you
would not believe it late
i think back to that night like i didn't
want to be there
i didn't know what i was going to say as
soon as he said 2000 i was like i'll be
there i'm really cool
all right
and a showtime wine bottle yeah a show
time
at least they took care of us it was a
nice little shoot yeah we had a little
room a little cute room was a great
theater really really you know you
learned from all those things
i still remember shooting kay loco no
the one before that the local comedy jam
i was on there with you no before that
the one that pat buckles did for jeff
valdez and i wanted to work clean on tv
i did two of those one with ari at the
studios in glendale wow remember that
one yeah i don't remember the studios in
glenn the host was like willie
carlos oscar
it was uh yes forgot what that was and
then we shot
k lokos i shot one of those they hated
me i did terrible that night no way oh
that was the spanish night at the at the
ice house i used to avoid it like the
plague does
avoid it like to play even if it i'd
only take the 40 bucks if like
god damn it i would go up there ready to
bomb the same thing with monday nights
at the last fight i was a 25 i was
checking those days wow the following
monday so gilbert put me up every
[ __ ] monday god bless his [ __ ]
soul even though james masada didn't
like me yeah every [ __ ] monday that
[ __ ] put me up i used to get you
up uh at my uh the patio remember el
patio
wednesdays on wednesday that [ __ ] would
crack
hot womenly
hot women
i was young i was crazy back then i was
like
i didn't i was like a cholo but i was
like a baggy clothes cholo back then
i was active and then well your buddy
ernie g had the room in universal city
on mondays that was a good yeah the
conga room the conga that was a good
room i did a lot of good jokes in that i
really did every monday night ernie got
a lot of problems but he always give me
the small 20 of a large 25 you know he'd
always save me i remember going there
one night dog with no [ __ ] dough
no dough no dough
and getting 20 from i was leaving the
next day to do the longest yard
and jeff gave me 45 bucks i went to jeff
garcia like a man like oh jeff i'm going
to new mexico i don't have no doubt
jeff because i give you what's in my
pocket like 46 bucks
damn you know i went and bought a 20 and
i kept 26 of it
and i took the 25 from ernie g and i
bought weed it was [ __ ] terrible jeff
valdez jeff garcia
to take to new mexico the next day the
20 dollars i had was jeff garcia how's
that for you
on a monday night
at the [ __ ] whatever that was up
there which was great the conga room
they had little snacks for us yeah
remember a lot of places had snacks
fears in those days and yeah it was like
a little like weird old guy that ran it
do you remember his buddy back then that
guy who ran the [ __ ] guy again you're
spilling [ __ ] it didn't spill what
happened some little weird guy used to
run that club
i don't remember him oh [ __ ] that's i
was such a rookie back then you know we
were talking about texas last week and
how much
how much i cut my comedy teeth in texas
i really did texas was el paso texas had
so many [ __ ] so much comedy it was
the pain rooms
i would go to texas and stay for four
[ __ ] weeks just driving through texas
a bunch of little rooms i go to conroe i
go to [ __ ]
midland i did every other the [ __ ]
water above
victoria i did every little town in
texas and they would [ __ ] hate me but
they feed me afterward
the comedy [ __ ] journey it really is
a weird journey yeah how many sets do
you think you've done
you figured for 10 years 10 to 12 years
i did 300 plus a year i've been doing
this for 24. you know my work ethic
right now if i go on the road i do five
a week plus the one at the comedy store
that's six
so if i go on the road twice in a month
that's 12. if i stay in i do three a
week plus one at the last factory so
that's eight and 12 is 20 a month even
now i'm still doing 250.
you've got to do 250 to maintain if
you're a [ __ ] real comic
listen i know what it's like to do
comedy six times a month and call
yourself a comic i know just like to do
comedy ten times a month i know what
it's like to do comedy 20 times a month
when you do [ __ ] comedy 20 20 times a
month you got a lot of ups and downs but
you're getting on stage and working out
do you think you've done it like 5 000
times maybe [ __ ] yeah you figured 300
times 20. what's 300 times 20. let's
find out let's figure it the [ __ ] out
because there were years i did 363. when
i first got to la in the first three
years i was
6 000. i was averaging 350
four damn because i was at the store
five nights a week plus the two with
willy's plus the one over here yeah
you're doing this rudy's room i was
doing ten nine seven [ __ ] sets a week
hosting at the store it's a complete
difference for a year i did jiu-jitsu
once a week
then i started picking it up twice a
week and i could see a little bit of
improvement
now there's some weeks i hit three times
a week and that's a good [ __ ] week
man yeah you sit there going wow i'm
moving better you know i can't wait to
get up to six times a week that's like
tommy you know you do it every day
you want to do it when you have a
passion like that you do it just the way
you do breathing [ __ ] you know i don't i
don't understand a comic that does not
get on stage yeah i i go up about five
times a week you know me i used to have
five rooms but you used to go up twelve
times the [ __ ] oh yeah i used to when
there were 12 yeah it's available if
there are
if i don't do a podcast i'm out if i
didn't do this on a monday night i'd be
picking up two sets tonight
plus two more sets on wednesday that's
four plus the tuesday at the store is
five thursday at the store is five
friday i take off and six a week that's
24 a [ __ ] month that's how and that's
the only way to [ __ ] do it yeah when
i lived in denver i did 16 sets a month
and i had to work like a dog that's
karaoke when i went to seattle i kicked
it up to 30 a month
and i could feel the improvement
the improvement just you know and then
you go on a triple run for six weeks
where you start a joke on a tuesday and
by saturday you got a bit if you're
working yeah if you're working if you're
in your car with your notebook making
notes and smoking dope that's what the
triple runs are for nobody's going to
see you you're in missoula montana
who's going to see if there's cbs you
could say whatever the [ __ ] you want out
of your mouth there's some clubs that
are mormons so you got to be careful
they'll tell you on the way in
but that's what a comedian does you get
on [ __ ] stage [ __ ] yeah i wrote
everything i don't know
that's nothing this [ __ ] did he
got up on stage and blew it up
saturday saturday before the special on
sunday that's what's up how much time
did you do
ah
oh [ __ ]
you know and that's what a lot of
i think that's the mistake of a lot of
people who come to town
you know a young comic you got to be at
the store on monday night that's a young
kid yeah trying to hustle hello goodbye
i tell you what before you hit the store
you hit a [ __ ] coffee shop or you hit
an open mic somewhere just to get the
set out of the way just to get the
number out of the way i'm here before
i'm going to the store right now you go
mingle you don't mingle you have a drink
you don't have a drink you get on stage
these comics that have a drink and men
go
i don't do nothing even in those days
when i was fiended out i don't do
nothing until i get on stage once you
get on stage then you talk and you
[ __ ] laugh and you giggle until you
get on stage i ain't going to [ __ ]
giggle about
you know when i was a young comic i get
up at 7 in the morning listen when i was
a thief
when i was a thief i get up at seven in
the morning i go you know what i got
four dollars for breakfast
but i gotta figure out what my next
score is for the day when you become a
comic and you open your eyes
beside
your first thought of the day which is
i'm alive i can't believe it i did coke
last night is
where am i doing comedy tonight
that's it while you're pissing while
you're pissing you're like it's tuesday
who do i got a call you're already
planning your [ __ ] your comedy day
hell yeah you're already planning your
[ __ ] comedy thing at seven in the
morning you're already thinking to
yourself okay it's tuesday i'm gonna go
here tonight i'm gonna go there tonight
i don't have nothing to do i don't know
you know i mean it's someone going over
there he's picking me up what am i
driving up there with it's [ __ ]
amazing yeah that's why i get blown away
at people who don't do much and then
they're like nothing's happening well
because you didn't you don't do this
call somebody
we felipe you
there was a handful of us that were out
five nights about edwin jeff and when
jeff goes out still i know i see him
he's gonna be at second base tomorrow he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah he loves it he
loves it every night he'll do the second
base to the haha yeah this is a guy
that's been doing comedy 20 [ __ ]
years ladies and gentlemen he is a
driver now
why he can't drive no it's just that
he's like he's gonna get [ __ ] up so he
has his assistant drive him to all the
clubs and like hey we can we're going to
get [ __ ] up but you can't
hilarious and she's pretty it's that one
girl always hangs around samantha right
yeah samantha
is that his sister
and no it's his babysitter and his
assistant okay no she multitasker
and it's
it's crazy because like
they're there and they're all partying
but it's cool jeff i love that dude he's
in he's
he don't care he's he's working he don't
care he's working god bless him he
really
frazier smith yeah he's out every night
with that
[ __ ] he does a radio show sundays at
11. you know
this is a guy that's been doing it for
30 years because this is second hand to
you you know you know i went to vegas
this weekend and i worked out hard all
week so friday i took the day off
saturday i was doing the special
i go you know what i'm not going to work
out the biggest [ __ ] mistake i made
on saturday yeah because that energy you
didn't get that energy get that energy
and then sunday i said [ __ ] it today i'm
gonna go [ __ ] work out you know and
it's so weird that when you don't work
like i was confused after i ate lunch
sunday something wasn't white right now
what did you eat nothing had a salad oh
but i went to my room and something
wasn't right i go
i know what this is i took a baby aspen
i wrapped my wrist
and i went right to that [ __ ] gym and
when i left it i was like how was how
did i do sunday night it was good it was
different [ __ ] better than the [ __ ]
yeah you know because it becomes second
nature working out does i don't it's how
you look at things okay that's how it's
always how you look at things you can
look at things as work or you can look
at things like i'm gonna go [ __ ] have
fun i [ __ ] hate getting on a plane
when i gotta go do comedy i always talk
to myself i try to talk myself out of it
and [ __ ]
but then i realize it's going to [ __ ]
be fun i'm going to go to a hotel i'm
going to eat something good from the
area i'm going to work out i'm going to
smoke pot i'm going to get to see some
people from twitter
crack some jokes try a few new jokes and
the worst case scenario i bring a check
home who [ __ ] lives like that who
gets to crack joke and mingle and
[ __ ] bring a check home but plus
you didn't do poorly on saturday you
killed it saturday
but the energy was completely different
than sunday so but sunday wasn't what i
don't think would have been people
walked out i got an email dog yeah guy
hit me up today he's like listen man i
went to see you from recommendation me
my wife and 10 other women walked out
and she said he goes cosby work clean
why can't you
first of all i'm happy that you and
those [ __ ] hags left
as a matter of fact cosby's a rapist you
[ __ ] idiot and next time have your
wife send me the email and go put a
tampon on something crazy because it's
true who writes an email like that on
monday [ __ ] to somebody me and my
wife [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] wife yeah
you should let her go and you stayed you
could have had a good time but you ain't
got no [ __ ] balls you got up and left
with it you want to hear a good [ __ ]
joke and take your wife upstairs and
[ __ ] her in the ass that's exactly what
you need somebody to suck that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dry and squeeze the [ __ ]
christian juice out of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's the end of that [ __ ]
i didn't like him because he was dirty
that's what the problem with those women
wow that's nobody's taking them and
tackled them shoulder down and rip those
[ __ ] panties off [ __ ] finger that
[ __ ] and then put your mouth on
that thing
suck that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're choking you're spitting back in
it you're sucking your own spit they
hear all that [ __ ] they're like this
[ __ ]
this motherfucker's running [ __ ] where's
tony bennet [ __ ] hell yeah man
the girls i'm with they call me prison
dick [ __ ] you know what i mean get that
burpee action going
my house playing [ __ ] attitude and
[ __ ]
it's monday [ __ ]
[ __ ] old [ __ ] of this [ __ ]
this guy's still singing at 80.
wow
are you [ __ ] kidding me
leela roo in the [ __ ] house tonight
ladies and gentlemen keep it up people
don't believe we're rocking
[ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] star this weekend was my
girl liz [ __ ] photographer
extraordinaire came out on an email
she was dynamite
she was trying to pervert leapfrog lee
was hiding in this room and she was
scared to be alone with it oh yeah
[ __ ] league we had a little
yeah
i know why too because you told me you
always like to be home one day to start
the week off i start the week off in
your own [ __ ] bed what are you making
i got a good idea what happened
no
well
what if we were released because we we
recorded sunday mm-hmm two but they
didn't we
everyone has the day off so we didn't
have the lights we could release that
one as like a
i still don't like working sundays so
like the lighting doesn't look that good
and it's like a kind of people walking
out
go back to your [ __ ] coma
look at the shape here you [ __ ] i love
it
how many nights is this in a row you've
been going straight since friday i have
no idea wednesday yeah but you were off
thursday thursday you went to vegas you
[ __ ] mocked around you lost money
even one money gambling this [ __ ] jew
this weekend yeah the two team paulie
and football he didn't [ __ ] around oh
[ __ ] he had dallas with romo breaking
when you [ __ ] take dallas and romo
breaks his [ __ ] collarbone and he's
still covering a bad [ __ ]
straight up yeah that's rosh hashanah
you know what i'm saying yeah as good as
but man you you what about you i didn't
do dick
yeah you just kicked it or what not
gambling was a special the special was
[ __ ] tremendous with you guys and
joey fulato came my buddy from jersey
and it's funny dog he's got a he had a
cousin that died god rest his soul he's
my brother i loved him with all my heart
he was a 24-hour [ __ ] criminal bro
but this guy was my biggest comedy
supporter okay and here i am 15 years
later with his [ __ ] cousin there with
me
i was at one point i was like what this
is like a spirit here the [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] when he was there he was [ __ ]
there darren
it was a great time man what about edwin
did you see edwin i didn't see that one
alone oh last time i saw i went in that
casino he sparked the [ __ ] joint i
almost choked them bro
i sparked the joint in the [ __ ]
casino i'm live and you're embarrassing
me this is why i do comedy yeah
yeah you know i didn't see anybody i
didn't [ __ ] even go to they do like a
comics reunion i didn't go to the
midnight listen man i got up at four in
the [ __ ] morning to go to santa to go
to las vegas friday morning
i did a show i [ __ ] did interviews i
made calls i tried to write then we shot
like a pseudo [ __ ] special just to
run through when i got out of there what
are we good we won an eight yeah and we
went back to the room and i went to
[ __ ] sleep jack you know i'm tired
yeah you know i can't [ __ ] stay out
no more and drink i have two drinks i
got heartburn
like a [ __ ] heartburn man you know
how bad i want a margarita but i'm gonna
have heartburn because these
[ __ ] put that sweet and sour
bubble [ __ ] drink in there i want the
real [ __ ] i want a cointreau with some
[ __ ] top shelf [ __ ] tequila
and some homemade [ __ ] lime juice
will you squeeze the [ __ ] limes
that's the margaritas i'm used to
drinking these [ __ ] harvey homos they
put [ __ ] that sweet and sour mix that
[ __ ] will give me ass indigestion for 12
[ __ ] years not even get [ __ ] ass
and just at home i don't suffer from
[ __ ] niger but every time i have a
margarita with that [ __ ] in my this guy
said he had a what'd you have that was a
long island that was all it was lemonade
look i used to eat quaaludes and drink
long island when i was like 17 at
janeiro's
in hoboken i used to get [ __ ] up dog a
good long island four light alcohol some
sweet and sour you get [ __ ] up you top
that [ __ ] with some good [ __ ]
you shake that [ __ ] up stop it
stop it with some [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits you get [ __ ] up jack damn i
would love to be able to drink a good
[ __ ] what is that
a long island it's everything it's it's
four light alcohols yeah a little bit of
coke
and [ __ ] sweet and sour who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with some
[ __ ] novices that's what i'm saying
it's like it's like what is it four or
six shots all in one until it's a big
drink it's a big [ __ ] drink for sure
but it could taste like [ __ ] or it
could taste delicious there's some
people that make a [ __ ] long island
that you don't even taste it going down
look i was drinking makers and cokes all
night
and i was i got
sober when i had a long island
like there was no alcohol in it it was
pretty crazy i remember when i was 17 we
used to sniff paint
that was the old school that was the
cholo [ __ ] back then you get that dutch
boy gold put it in the brown bag
how [ __ ] up is the kitchen
it's like about like smoking five blunts
all that now why do you get pimples on
your neck because sticky charlie this
gate when i was a guy whenever we used
to make him smoke paint oh yeah he would
snort like rust rust-oleum yeah he would
snort [ __ ]
dog and he would get after like a week
he would get zits on because he's
scratching himself something like that
boils they were like blisters plus like
when people touch dope it's in your
hands and it goes in your pores that's
why a lot of tweakers they scratch their
heads and they get these big old scabs
i used to get that yeah
my head on my face my
i'd be picking that [ __ ] till
four in the morning with the coke yeah
[ __ ] squeezing [ __ ] and guts out of
my face like an hour
that's why i'm all [ __ ] scarred up i
can't believe you started painting i
thought about it hi i thought i ate
[ __ ] cat food at a party one night
and smoked a cigarette that type of [ __ ]
you understand what are you supposed to
do they said you get [ __ ] up you eat a
little cat food out of a bag and you
smoke some [ __ ] cigarettes and
something that [ __ ] you up i was like
[ __ ] 12 what the [ __ ] did i know what
i'm saying dude the crazy [ __ ] i did
recently is i didn't know but this guy
cut coke with adderall
and [ __ ]
is it crazy
it's like
the i don't know it's like i don't know
it'd be like smoking speed and then
someone snuck in like a big old rock hit
so it was like you're up but then you
were like
panicking
you know what i mean you were like
tweaking and then like but you were in
panic mode and it was just like what the
[ __ ] no no no no no no that didn't sound
good i know that's what [ __ ] it up but
then like
it would fade away
it was weird
it was [ __ ] weird i remember i stayed
until like six in the morning george i
wish
that i'm not proud of this but i wish
that everybody got to taste cocaine in
1980.
oh and what it would do to you
i thought i heard i heard it was
what they did to the cocaine
to get more out of it and what the
chemicals they put out here that there's
some coke going around that eats your
skin
yeah with this thing that was up in the
northeast oh my god you know i was doing
coke towards the end that was [ __ ]
half speed
i was doing coke that you know yeah i
don't know
sweating
and drinking like six in the morning
no
in 1980 when you did a blast like
the first time i did coke i got a lie no
but i didn't get [ __ ] high at all i
didn't know what the [ __ ] people were
talking about
i thought people were playing a trick on
me like everybody's like this [ __ ] is
tremendous i'm like
eagle white people faking first he was
laughing at saturday night live that
[ __ ] ain't funny and now you're telling
me this [ __ ] gets you high and you feel
like you're floating once i had a drink
with it
yeah that's where it gets yeah i just
wanted to [ __ ] zoom me my sure
still remember
and i talked to my cousin
the the cousin that didn't
call me back i got very hurt and one day
out of the blue i got a call and they
say and he goes dog i don't check my
facebook my girlfriend found my old
facebook and found the message
and we were talking you know we've been
getting cozy and cozy uh-huh and i asked
him i remember the time he picked me up
in the airport you took me to the
trailer and there was an old man that
was like [ __ ] 16 he was [ __ ] a 16
year old chick and he had a stroller
have fun he was doing coke with a robot
it was [ __ ] tremendous to see
and i asked him did he want to do a bump
he's like no no no i've been bumping
myself all afternoon he's cuban and [ __ ]
i remember he gave me some coke that all
our eyes were red
wow like i never forget sit in the car i
just got off the airport nobody smoked
pot and we did two little bumps and we
drove we had to pull over that's how
high you used to get you couldn't see
your your your vision
played with you yeah like your vision
play with you and the
taste
going down your throat
when you go
yeah it's a wrap wrote what
i mean lee
cocaine from 80
to 85 in this country
was amazing and then what happened they
couldn't snuck they couldn't sneak ether
into colombia
so they started cutting it with
turpentine and gasoline oh and that's
where crack came in that's why people go
i can't snort this [ __ ] dog i bought
nine ounces from danny b one time they
called the cat piss
this coke was electric you got [ __ ] up
on a little taste but you could only you
could only do four bucks
the smell in your nose was horrific dog
you
i would cut it and people were bringing
it back it was [ __ ] horrendous you
take that coat you rock that [ __ ] up
with some paint
and you you sell 10 rocks all day people
don't give a [ __ ] that because it burns
that [ __ ] out when you smoke it
so that's where the flavor went that's
and they even explained that to you on
narcos that the hardest part the only
thing they don't tell you on narcos is
how they were processing coke in cuba
they figured out how to get ether into
cuba 90 miles away so it was a lot
easier process to coke
so now that coke that tasted good went
up
and the coke that tasted shitty was down
so when you went to buy coke from a real
d lego i got two options for you yeah i
got this [ __ ] for 110. i got this [ __ ]
for 90. and the [ __ ] for 90 was
sensational it just had a weird taste it
had like gasoline taste or a turpent or
it smelled like feet cheese some people
had cheese coke for a while it was
unbearable so but that was my question
the good coke still exists it's just
more expensive
yeah it still exists if you get it from
like people that get it from like mexico
but if you're getting it from another
race it's it's i think mexicans are
cutting it with something they're
they're making they're doing something
yeah they're making amphetamines in
mexico
i was in texas last time i was a mcallen
forget about it over there oh [ __ ] over
there like weed was the hardest thing to
find coke was like everybody had
everybody has it was like eight feet in
the stall you ever go by a stall and you
see eight feet it was like
oh yeah i i bought a challenge of brutal
yeah i took butch escobar with me he
only ate twice
and how many days
four
remember i told you we stayed at that
guy's house and he had the jesus foot
with the nail in it he's still booked in
the room yeah
but you don't stay at the house no more
where do you stay you stay at the
schedule hotel okay i'm still not going
down no no
i was scared that i was [ __ ] a cop
back then when i went
it was it was crazy it was crazy
i'll tell you later a cop down there
yeah from westlake
you still talk to her nah
i started dating someone so i i stopped
but you know i was only down there twice
it's it's that that's when you do
brawley no you don't do brawler you do
uh
mcallen weslaco
and you do la jolla and la jolla is like
30 miles from the border i wouldn't say
30. i would say like three
three miles from the border and there's
no security guards it's all like border
patrol
like at the bars
and it was weird it was the first time i
didn't care if i didn't get paid i
remember i performed and i got off stage
and i was like i need to get out of here
dude
like i need to get out of here me joey
me cause i can tell everybody look at me
they're like hey homie you ain't from
around here
the mexicans over here don't don't don't
have nikes
you know what i mean it was weird i was
like
they gave me my money though and they're
like hey let's go and then it it it was
crazy
no there's some places i've been to that
you're like you know what
i won't be coming back you know
these [ __ ] are gonna be ready
for me three times no they're gonna know
figure out i'm in a hotel and then
getting paid with cash
it's [ __ ] crazy
it's [ __ ] crazy you really you know
you can see the hunger in their face one
time i had a problem one time up north
the football coach that used to book
friday nights and the one time me and
rodrigo and felipe went and i thought i
bought coke but i bought matt i did it
anyway i got [ __ ] up in that room i
was chewing those cigarettes
i was lighting them and then you could
see them going
i put them on i had there was so much
smoke in the room felipe's like bro you
have to open up the door that's how much
smoke there was in the [ __ ]
i had three packs of camel lights i was
smoking one after the other on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's what that speed
does to you man oh my god
i remember we used to smoke it out of
like a water bong my friend would put
root beer
and we put ice cream in it and
when speed tastes good you don't know
how much you're smoking
that was some [ __ ] insane [ __ ] we
stole cars back then
you would make root beer float
and how do you snort the speed up no you
don't you burn it it's like a bong
because you have a
you have it in a glass stem that has a
hole and then you have another stem
that's going into the water and the ice
cream or the bong so the smoke is
hitting that and then you're sucking it
out
it tastes like a root beer hell yeah
root beer eating [ __ ] meth like a
[ __ ]
i've never smoked man oh my god let's go
smoke some methane
i'm upset man
that was back then though i didn't know
you know what i mean remember when you
didn't know what you were doing was bad
you're like hey man everyone else did it
you know what i mean like hey i want to
finish my homework in one day [ __ ] it
let's go
it was crazy there was something about
speed
that i did it if it was around but it
wasn't my first choice yeah exactly
i sold black beauties in high school i
was telling lee
and then in 80 and 80.
when i was in high school one night i
went to a strip club and some bikers
were there some guy asked me if i wanted
to buy speed and i bought some crank
whatever they call that crank that's
exactly the way it's called it was uh
it wasn't a powder it was like little
chunks it was like that peanut butter
brown i bought it no this is white this
is all wow new jersey this is 1980
and i thought i was grabbing like 80
bucks and then we did it we got [ __ ]
up but it wasn't my calling and i didn't
do it again
to idaho i went to the boise idaho funny
bone that was opening up for christopher
titus oh wow the waitresses were real
cool it's a hippie town at the time and
the waitress took me to this bar to
drink pictures and i'm like man i'd go
for a bump and she's like i can't get
your blow but i got tons and they used
to put you in this historic hotel that
was like there from the 1800s when i
went up to that [ __ ] room that room
started creaking yeah those floors
started creaking i was up for three
[ __ ] days on two little lines of
crank and you know i watched on
television that night without knowing
joe rogan was on the dirty dozen on
showtime oh hosted by don herrera in
1998 that was a series they did 12
episodes a dirty dozen
just three comics the show and i
remember seeing joe rogan and going i
don't know what that [ __ ] guy is
with a hat on and [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i
was on speed that night yeah the show
came out at 11. i'm i was thinking how
can i get on that [ __ ] i've been doing
comedy
maybe
10
no i had been doing it was before la it
was way before like 96
summer in 96 yes
yes because we were all going to the
boise funny bone from seattle that's
when me and josh wolf robbed that
restaurant that's the alibi he had that
he was at the boise the chick liked them
the chicken was a little hippie chick
that thought she was a comedy girl that
[ __ ] is long gone from comedy
and she used to book that room that was
a fun little [ __ ] room boise boise
funny bone was a great little five or
six days
but i did [ __ ] heavy duty speed up
that was [ __ ] up then i went to west
virginia on a creative run one night i
asked these good old boys
where i could get some [ __ ] and they're
like take a ride with us
i drove an hour into the weeds dog into
a [ __ ] trailer like breaking bad i
didn't know nothing about nothing
i gave the guy 40 bucks he came out with
a bag of that [ __ ]
how good is this coke he goes it's coke
we don't sell coke around here that [ __ ]
is cranked
i did it i didn't give a [ __ ] jack and
that [ __ ] burns your nose crank is
just viciously at vicious and you know
whatever no and then when i got locked
up
oh [ __ ] you got it in there when i got
locked up there was a white dude clark
either john clark mike clark john clark
solid white dude tatted up six foot one
everybody knew this [ __ ] was out
of his mind but he was solid dog and on
sundays he'd go in and swap spit with
his girlfriend and she leave the balloon
in his mouth yeah and he'd come get me
and i'd stay up all night saturday all
night sunday visitation and then all day
monday but monday nights was basketball
in the gym across the street so i try to
play basketball on the speed that's
completely different than me oh [ __ ]
your heart can't your heart can't
[ __ ] handle that [ __ ] that's why when
people go long as taylor was playing on
cocaine i'm always like i don't think so
have you ever done yeah not every
quarter no you can't be [ __ ] shooting
and [ __ ] [ __ ] no i couldn't imagine
doing a line of coke and trying to shoot
a 20-footer and [ __ ]
straight up or like trying to tackle the
quarterback like he's playing with the
best of the best lawrence taylor he was
taking some hits but not all game
you think so yeah he had to he had to i
remember in high school i smoked speed
like before a game once
just because it was just like but i
oh yeah
you know it's crazy when i was a kid
armando rudy used to tell me bro wait do
you play basketball you smoke a joint
when you gonna do a layer you just keep
going and the ball rolls off your
fingers and i'm like oh my god how can
you play basketball smoking weed first
time i [ __ ] did it i fell in love
with it anything smoking weed like that
type of [ __ ] where you could think and
react different and see what the [ __ ] is
crack-a-lacking what's up lisa how you
feeling would you for dinner tonight
[ __ ] like
i haven't had dinner yet because i slept
all day you slept all day and then i
went to the gym yeah you slept all
[ __ ] day well we had a [ __ ] early
flight
well you didn't i just i slept good this
weekend though
i was i was telling you something about
sleep bro let me tell you something
about sleep i [ __ ] my sleep up half of
this stomach
it's not sleeping
if you don't sleep bro your body don't
burn
yeah he doesn't do it i didn't know this
i didn't know this at a young age i
thought that [ __ ] these [ __ ] that sleep
eight hours they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're missing like
you gotta get your eight to seven every
night yeah you gotta charge the battery
you know i remember last year i was
gaining a lot of weight and i looked you
know that's when we were doing the
church at [ __ ] six
and then i would get up at five to fly
out thursday and then get up at friday
for radio
east coast which is three in the morning
and then you're getting up at [ __ ]
sunday to fly the [ __ ] back
no i had to cut it out it was too i
couldn't figure out why i was putting
weight i was weight watchers i lost 130
pounds on weight watchers now i'm on
weight watchers gaining [ __ ] weight
i'm like you know why you don't [ __ ]
sleep you gotta [ __ ] sleep i tell you
man last night i went to the hotel room
i went all my sides
and something was coming on that i ran
out of watch
and i remember i said click i turned
that [ __ ] off
and some you know what i used to say if
i'm not in bed in 10 minutes i'll put it
back on you can't do that now you got to
[ __ ] commit to [ __ ] sleep and you
know what you fall asleep you eat three
stars you smoke a joint you [ __ ] fall
asleep unless you're [ __ ] yeah
unless it just jumps you up for 10
minutes i go home i smoke some tv and
drink a cup of coffee i go what goes up
must come down
nice and [ __ ] dead
but that's big man that's what that's
why i'm doing better on the road
you look better you look arrested
i'm the type of [ __ ] that could
go six nights on four hours and think
it's cheap
and that [ __ ] don't you could do all the
lifting you could drink all the water
you could do whatever the [ __ ] you want
you ain't gonna be [ __ ] healthy so
now what i do is when i'm on the road i
let myself stay up late you know what
i'm not gonna fight with i just did a
show what do you wanna do right i gotta
know where to go tomorrow i go to bed at
three dog i wake up at 6 30
i put a little cup of coffee on i do a
little writing
i smoke a [ __ ] joint i get two eggs
with a piece of wheat toast and three
slices of bacon a fruit cup
i put on whatever the [ __ ] is on my
favorite show is gang land if it's
friday and i do that [ __ ] i got no radio
i throw gangland on if you're on the
east coast ganglion goes to three or
four in the afternoon i'm learning about
everybody the m13s i know knowledge on
all the [ __ ] gangs
and then i go back to sleep till about
twelve or one and dog three and four or
seven i'm good
four salad after a joint and breakfast
two eggs put my [ __ ] right to [ __ ]
sleep yeah and i did that all three days
in vegas so i knew monday morning i had
to go right to an audition i could not
stay out [ __ ] friday night they want
to eat late because i didn't want that
[ __ ] in my stomach when i'm sleeping
that's another thing you go to bed at 12
and you eat a [ __ ] sandwich you're
not going to fall asleep your stomach is
digesting it you're going to have
nightmares that you're in the deli
getting [ __ ] in the end you'll eat
like a pepperoni sandwich late night
that spicy [ __ ] next thing yeah deli and
the sopranos are [ __ ] you up the ass
you're like but i had those type of
dreams because your [ __ ] whole body
is to try to [ __ ] digest the food i
used to love to eat late night bro i'm a
[ __ ] believer right after comedy good
[ __ ] steak before you go to bed you
sleep like a baby no you don't your
body's up all [ __ ] night you sleep
you're going to the third decibel you're
supposed to hit six you're on three do
you like a1 steak sauce
it was all over the east coast and i
haven't had it for years and now i'm
just remembering how disgusting it is
i've put a one-state source they used to
be a place in new york city called tad
steakhouse they got one in san francisco
kansas city let me tell you some 30
years ago though
you're going to attach steakhouse for
6.95 to give you a t-bone a baked potato
a salad a thing of jell-o and a soda it
wasn't a bad steak it wasn't you know
was that a lot of money back then six
bucks was like 15 now 29 okay so i go in
there and i tell the guy yo let me get a
steak and i look at them i make because
they cook the thing was they cooked the
steak in front of you but it was
cafeteria stuff oh so i would tell the
guy i put a fin on the guide dog you
know what man
money talks and [ __ ] walks like make
eye contact with the guy and right over
the counter right there without nobody
saying i'd give him a fin he'd open up
the tray in front of me and i'd go pick
the best one in that [ __ ] i see
him looking around for the thick ones
the ones they had here and they throw
one of those things on for joey
medium [ __ ] well he'd carry it down
the [ __ ] line
you pick up your tossed salad with rant
in those days i used to use french
dressing when i was a kid i love french
dressing yeah what color is that
puke yeah it's like an orange [ __ ]
puke with chunks in it french and
russian that was my [ __ ] when i was a
kid though
with some lettuce and some tomatoes and
some raw onions some salt and pepper you
mix that [ __ ] up good that orange [ __ ]
[ __ ] delicious yeah and you got jello
with cube and you put some whipped cream
on that [ __ ] wow that's such an
old school meal oh my god
i love jello that's the white man in me
oh yellow or whipped
oh [ __ ] when i was in prison they give
jello all night i'll give you my milk
yeah i'll give you my milk for jello dog
give me milk and there was like a good
portion they gave you that give me a
little yeah it costs two [ __ ] it
costs minus two cents for [ __ ] ten
cents you can make a tray of [ __ ]
jelly you ever notice that you could eat
jello for a year for a dollar fifty you
get another can of whipped cream who's
better than you i [ __ ] around with my
jello in the old days they used to have
a jello mix that you would make and you
had to get a glass and then tip it in
the refrigerator nobody remembers this
[ __ ] nobody remember you remember at
least that had to be like hot or
something chubby kids did that [ __ ] yeah
it's like boil it or something yeah then
put it in and put it in and the bottom
would get dark the middle and it would
get light and you took one that [ __ ] put
whipped cream on it good googly moogly
good googly moogly
thank you have you ever had an ice box
cake no what is the ice bucket oh it's
so [ __ ] good my friends filipino she
makes them for a living part time i the
one the one my mom makes is just like
the in like instead of like the instant
jello it's an instant pudding and you
make that and it's like layers of that
and graham crackers and then you put it
in the freezer until it freezes and then
just adding whipped cream good googling
it's amazing
for three days
where'd you grow up george i grew up in
orange county orange and you play high
school football yeah i played basketball
football
and [ __ ] around like a [ __ ]
you had all the recipes to be a regular
kid didn't you yeah you know i
yeah i was just
everybody that i grew up with was like
yo man there's there's another gang
over there so we're just gonna make our
own gang and it wasn't even like race it
was everybody that lived on that side of
town it didn't matter mexican hell no we
had mexican filipino white
it was indian
yeah it was it was it was fun but like
we weren't the kind of people that were
like hey dog like if you got a family
you got to go we're still friends you
know we were just like uh
they should do a gang land about you
like the night hell no i'll never get on
that [ __ ] and talk
uh gangland that's for like people that
want to be like i don't i don't even
know those guys are real i don't think
so either i look down sometimes they're
like hey homie you ain't no dude yeah we
were selling kilos then why are you
[ __ ] telling this story exactly like
what the [ __ ] like you get to say it and
play it that's crazy i sold some ounces
that was a loser deal i didn't make a
[ __ ] dime i snorted every [ __ ]
dime i ever made yeah
i was a loser [ __ ] coke deal i made
money for a while and i turned around
i'd make a little money and slot that
[ __ ] down
you know the the black crew from atlanta
did you ever see that one no whatever
brothers that had the party they made
rap videos and they paid somebody a half
a million to do a rap video yeah
those guys like 20 of them they all have
maseratis
they came the twins the two brothers one
brother that they found them in miami
and the other brother had 92 cars they
designed the cars with the compartments
in them so you could travel all around
some of those gang lands are [ __ ]
interesting yeah yeah i have to see that
i think the black ones are real i really
do i think the black ones are real i
think that i always watch those and i
always ask myself why didn't i ever get
involved with those people like when i
grew up there was no gang of things
no there was a biker gang that when i
was really young a freshman in eighth
grade i go up down i'd walk past their
house and they'd invite me in and they'd
give me a beer i don't know who the [ __ ]
they were but gang is this kid now where
i live there's latin kings yeah now
where i live i hear that there's
lightning kings
from new york and they're in union city
and i saw something about unity latin
kings you watch those shows and see it i
love those prison shows yeah oh yeah
i've seen all of them i can't watch them
anymore i've seen all no there's a new
one with guards yeah the rookie guys in
training the rookies
that's just funny i found the syringe
the other night i was gonna watch the
second one that's the show i was gonna
turn it off i like those shows so much i
found there was a show on netflix a
while ago about the
cops at mall of america it's like a 12
episode
one season show i watched all of it and
they're investigating like sweatshirts
and crazy weird [ __ ] but just
like those shoes are so fun to watch but
because it's so scary it's just weird
i'm even surprised you guys watch them
i watch them because like i lived it and
i want to see how accurate it is
at the end of the day i give it like my
overall rating i'll be like oh [ __ ] like
that really did happen so yeah
i'm like a judge is that your rating
like you're like this one got the oh
[ __ ] yeah like hey damn dog i remember
something like that happened when i was
there
so yeah it's pretty weird for me i watch
it and i think about the situation i got
myself into how bad it really could have
been
i see those guys yeah 30 years my first
pleat bargain was 12 years and
kidnapping
one
damn he was a black attorney sunny
flowers in fact somebody just hit me up
and he kind of like was part of them you
know he was the black guy that hi how
you doing my name is
so the first deal he came at me with was
12 years
and he came at me with kidnapping two
and nine years but a violent crime you
do nine years yeah from the parole board
man
so think about though my life would have
been completely [ __ ] different
completely different just just a couple
years yeah just a couple years six
months that day that some guy said
something i hit him with a shiv and now
you pick up another three now you got a
jacket that now you go somewhere higher
and you stab some you know a thousand
that's when i watch those shows i get
entertained but at the same time my
mind's drifting
because i'm thinking what if that's me
though that's me i watched the episode
where the guy said something he goes
well and he stepped up to the police guy
i did that a few times but i knew in the
back of my head you're not getting
nowhere you're just having a bad [ __ ]
day
you're just having a bad day hey dog put
those sneakers away [ __ ] you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you i'm over here and you don't
even know because there's days where
these four walls do get to you these 60
[ __ ] guys or these hundred guys do
get to you yeah you have bad days and
good days is it scary when you see it
because i saw a fist fight today and it
was like kinda i i didn't know if i
should go to the store or not like the
people were just fighting outside of a
store you just walk in mind your [ __ ]
business
listen if they're going to shoot each
other they're going to shoot each other
within the first three minutes they have
a gun if they're out there swinging it
out if one guy goes down he gets up and
he runs through his car and you [ __ ]
run yeah but if he's not you know it's
like that scene and good guys wear black
in the beginning but the guy goes let me
go get my money out of my car he gets a
gun and he comes back that's it you got
a problem once they go into the car you
start running like a [ __ ] that's
got nothing to do with you but a good
fish fight you got to watch from time to
time just to see
how [ __ ] up it is out there how [ __ ]
up and how quick this could happen
straight up quick you could be walking
with paula down the street and some guy
don't like that shirt he's drunk and
he'll say something he'll smack you in
front of paul how [ __ ] fast that
could happen that's a reality it could
happen to me walking down the street
with my wife i walk at the route there's
two dudes they're just having a bad day
one kicks me in the stomach that's how
fast that's how fast that's how fast
your life can change man the reason why
i stopped playing blackjack last night
was this dude came in and sat down next
to us and said hey what casino man
and the thing about the south point is
it's not next to anything it's not like
the stripper could be in any like any of
a thousand casinos there's only one
casino there
so he started saying weird [ __ ] to the
poor little like 18 year old dealer girl
with blonde hair he's like i have rope
somewhere
and like just like he's like i see he's
not he's like i get kicked out of places
you're just getting real creepy
i get kicked out
it's not for nothing
every [ __ ] casino
is creepy as [ __ ] yeah
listen i don't care where you go dog
when you're walking through those
casinos
you see people yeah the vibe changes
automatically i don't care where the
[ __ ] casino they're at from the sls
to the south point to that [ __ ] hotel
we saw when we were pulling out when we
were going with somebody were you with
us always meet joyful out and his wife
we're going to do mma junkie on the way
to mandalay bay
we saw a hotel we're like who the [ __ ]
stays in there
people stay in that dog
vegas is the real deal
holy feel
listen man
i want to give some shout outs my man
bradford
uh get well [ __ ] i know your
achilles tendon johnny and laura
congratulations i want to give a shout
out to my brother burbank818
[ __ ] telling people to retweet and
[ __ ] get it together you [ __ ] you
know i love you my favorite [ __ ]
armenian
zack bjork gustavo cedeno john murphy
daniel riley
amy
and my man dave john cutler for sending
me a beautiful [ __ ] latin jazz cd
but the shout out this week goes to lisa
and talking laughs for [ __ ] being uh
the anchors of the special
this episode
shout out to you and my man talking
later john he even brought me nutter
brothers he probably oreos but he
couldn't take it brother oreos too i
brought him home i still didn't dig into
them
he got me a strawberry shortcake i mean
that guy is very good to me i love him
like a bro like i said you meet people
on this twitter issue that you end up
falling in love i would move
to vegas because i knew that talking
late was dead
they had my back you know those people
yeah you called four in the morning
they're like i'll be there with a
bazooka and i got some throwing stars
that's talking late you know tokyo would
have like a little camera set up there
just he'd already know like even before
he called people like uh i'm already on
the way joey
no this just uh
all that [ __ ] was great so it's five
years you've been out think of all the
things you did in five years george
perez from the from the [ __ ] shows
with your boy from the 70s show well you
did that before you got locked up yeah i
did that before i got so when you went
to prison you were celebrating that
people wanted to [ __ ] jam with your
mama jokes yeah nobody knew until like
later like my last year and a half or
two years maybe that's when everybody
was just like hey dog we cuz like
we found a way to get mtv3 on our tv
like the homie that did like electricity
plug the main wire for like the dorm
into the to the tv room
so mtv tres comes out and it's old
reruns of your mama and everybody's like
looking like is that [ __ ] you
and i was like yeah then after that it
was just like bada bing
you know what i mean but i really didn't
want no one to talk to me i i didn't
want i don't know the less friends you
have is the better right
why why do you want to be a celebrity in
there but it happened and i and i ran
with it
as far as like uh living life
i mean it was cool but it wasn't at the
same time you know how it is other races
are just like
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're funny when
did you get out george i got out in 2009
you know
i got locked up in 2006. for me it's not
who i was
but it's who i am like i got locked up
i'm not ashamed of it i don't give a
[ __ ] i got locked up i did something
wrong
i paid my debt at the time i could have
gone to [ __ ] honduras and rented cars
and i could have come back now where
would my life be i wouldn't have my own
life no you'd be on the run still you
know i i i remember months
before the thing i thought i was going
to be the kidnapping case like that's
how delusional i was like i was i knew i
wasn't going to take it to court
but i had a doubt i'm like i'll kill the
[ __ ] victim you know
i wanted him to disappear i thought he
would disappear on his own but he didn't
yeah he's still alive but the point
being that it's like
i still think about it once a day every
[ __ ] day
at some point of the day i think about
my mother
i think about my friends what they mean
to me i think about doing that straight
whether it's two minutes on the bus ride
or
you know laughing in jail when you laugh
in jail you [ __ ] laugh like i laugh
those black [ __ ] are [ __ ]
high
hilarious with a capital h
from doc i remember i started for the
first two weeks i didn't giggle or
nothing and then diagnostic
i would [ __ ] howl
because there was a black dude that
would call his wife every night yell at
that for 20 minutes
like it would start off good like yeah i
miss you and [ __ ] honey yeah i'm over
here with the cube of this [ __ ] and then
like you know you call them
and you get collect calls yeah the
conversation return after like eight
minutes and they would start yelling at
each other the phone and then they would
go [ __ ] you [ __ ] don't call back and
he'd hang up on honey go to the cell
they'd go she didn't she can't call you
you just ended the phone call in a bad
way now all night you're gonna be
thinking about that beef and you call
can't call that [ __ ] back i apologize
now you gotta write letters all night
and make sure the [ __ ] horse leaves
on time at five a.m
it's a [ __ ] nightmare to have an
argument with your girlfriend but that's
not the point of hand the point i had
was
how for me i wear it with a badge on
like if you go to vietnam for me you
come back with a mouth that's what i did
because it was i did get a medal from it
no i got a medal from you
yeah it's an experience i got a medal
from going to prison because i did
something with what i learned i talked
about it today and i did something with
it you know i was talking to talking
lair and he was talking about success
and what success is to me
listen man
i'm happy about one thing in this life i
did something with my life
it's not even about success guys it's
not about success
it's at 40 years old
you pay a mortgage you're not the
richest guy in the world
you got 280 in the bank you got 600 in
your christmas club you got a nice wife
a few kids
and so what you didn't become president
so what you didn't make it to the boston
red sox so what you're not driving a
maserati you're way better off than a
lot of [ __ ] people
and the most important thing you did
something with your life these people
that dream of being celebrities or
wanting to see celebrities or i'm gonna
do this and i'm gonna do that
that's all great and dandy but they're
not happy with what the [ __ ] they have
i've been happy with myself for like
[ __ ] five years man
just waking up in the morning
who needs a million dollars that's what
you need to make you happy boy are you
gonna have a hard [ __ ] life
because that's what i thought
until about 30 that's what i thought if
you didn't have 50 000 in your pocket
you weren't gonna have no friends then
you realize who the [ __ ] wants friends
if i need forty thousand dollars yeah i
want friends like this [ __ ] they'll
go cheer they'll die live and die for
you and they you know he knows the same
for me we don't we don't even [ __ ]
you know it's not like i [ __ ] pay his
rent or nothing like that he works for
his [ __ ] money man
so
it's so weird like for me i'm just happy
that i'm not locked up i'm happy that
i'm not living in a [ __ ] basement
before other guys smoking crack do you
ever have nightmares about being locked
up like like you get locked up again i
used to get that a lot i have nightmares
about everything
i have nightmares about people doing
blow with me about women
man
listen where i came from if i don't have
a nightmare once a week or a bad dream
i'm not real you gotta you have to live
this [ __ ] in your mind somewhere i tell
people all the time you gotta check on
your skeletons bro from time to time
because if not they're gonna check on
your [ __ ] ass and that's not a
good check now sometimes at night i
smoke a [ __ ] joint my mind goes
somewhere i start thinking about the
dark times and [ __ ] and i relive it i
cry a little bit
you know i giggle and i go [ __ ] that's a
scary time i do the sign of the cross
and i leave that [ __ ] thought
where the [ __ ] it is you know
i write sometimes in the morning i
remember [ __ ] like i'm trying to write
the story for harry's thing talk i was a
hellion i robbed this dude and i caused
a lot of havoc
and you know you think about all that
[ __ ] and i can feel bad about it that
that's not the person i am today it's
not at all you know yeah i go back in
time a lot too and i just trip out like
[ __ ] like back in my era like we fought
a lot you know what i mean like we
really i wasn't the kind of kid that
stole ship because i remember one time
we tried to do like a home invasion i
was just like we couldn't get in the
house i was happy i was like [ __ ] dude
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
i remember just going i gotta go to
football practice like in two hours what
the [ __ ] is going on
just that word
home invasion i have i did those things
in drugs but i don't look at them as a
home invasion because just the word home
invasion makes me [ __ ] nervous yeah
makes you nervous the last time i did
that with my buddy and i went in there
with a gun dog i don't believe in that
going somebody could have [ __ ] shot
me he used to yeah with the [ __ ] suit
on without the dna jacket guys you have
no [ __ ] idea what fear is you have no
[ __ ] idea what fear is bro i was
telling you how you go deaf
every time i was about to do something
bad bro i would go deaf and i could feel
my heart beat every
movement in my chest
pink floyd fight showtime yeah that's
the same adrenaline you get when you get
into a fight or you got a knife pulled
on you the cops are chasing you but when
i would crawl through a window i was
ripping your [ __ ] apart looking for that
coat i still remember that kid in that
belt when i went back and ripped his
heart
he had one of those ceilings suspended
ceilings that have the cubes inside that
you pick them up and you can hide [ __ ]
in there yeah off the ceiling
i never forget that i jumped up and
grabbed onto those feelings at that time
i was 220 to 25
and i remember with every [ __ ] piece
of strength i heard i ripped that
[ __ ] ceiling down the whole building
heard it
the whole building heard the thing going
i didn't give a [ __ ] i was deaf my heart
was pumping i cut my hand you used to
cut yourself that's why i knew oj killed
his wife because when you're killing the
[ __ ] you're adrenaline you don't
feel it in your hand you ain't feeling
it i wouldn't feel [ __ ] when i got back
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this oh
[ __ ] i gotta call in a barbed wire you
know i'm [ __ ] bleeding you wouldn't
[ __ ] feel it i would go up to a
window smash it open the window crawl in
and cut yourself for something on the
way in you're ripping [ __ ] you're
opening up desks you're throwing dishes
you're looking for [ __ ] man
what do you think you look for [ __ ]
neatly yeah when i rob people i knew i
didn't make a mess you know what i'm
saying but if i didn't know him you have
to make a [ __ ] mess if you know you
can't make a mess you want you want the
element of [ __ ] surprise you know
what i'm saying
what's up lisa you little [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] you it was just a great
weekend man it was uh
it's fun to see do you finally do it
special 24 [ __ ] years i did
pieces on it and i never did the special
nobody was going to offer me a special
george you know you just did it on your
own independence and i told leah and we
and lee had conversations i called him
like a week ago and i told him what was
gonna happen i go listen i'm gonna do it
people gonna jump on they want to help
nobody's gonna [ __ ] sell it we're
gonna get nothing we're gonna get
[ __ ] nothing
let's just do it ourselves
we'll make a little money we won't make
nothing at least i did it yeah it's
better than sitting there going we'll do
it november we'll do it in january
that's what we're doing for two [ __ ]
years you know me yeah i procrastinate
like anybody [ __ ] else you know and
lee kept pushing me i got to give him
credit
and finally i just put two and two
together i said i'll do it there
and that's it you know hopefully you'll
do one soon and we could be on the same
[ __ ] network together yes yes i'm
actually working on it myself so we'll
see what's going on because you know it
does it takes a while you got to get the
right money the right location i don't
want to like
do it and like go around cut corners you
know what i mean i want to do it legit
well here's the problem with specials
the cds
but if a company comes to you they're
going to go well george perez we really
love you we're really we're going to put
about 80 000 into your cd
tellingly
you know if you wire the [ __ ] room
and put it into the thing it don't cost
no eighty thousand
who you gonna call
comedy247 they'll do it for [ __ ] free
uh what the rapper
on the cd and the cases you get 50 cases
for two [ __ ] dollars
so what cost what's the 80 [ __ ]
thousands go shoot a special talk to
people about shooting specials it's 200
000
i want to know where
what does that cover the 10 first class
seats for everybody to come and drink
that's what that covers let's shoot a
special three four [ __ ] hotel
rooms a flight the rental
the cameras everybody works for a
[ __ ] little piece of a back end let's
see what we can [ __ ] do here that's
how you [ __ ] shoot a [ __ ] special
at the end you go wow i spent eighteen
thousand what were they talking about
for three hundred thousand like new wave
we spend a hundred and fifty thousand
yeah i'm sure you [ __ ] do no you
don't you pay all these [ __ ]
immigrant wages
you pay them six but you tell me you pay
them 12. you follow on thank you yeah so
that six goes right into your [ __ ]
pocket that's that's what the mafia did
for 20 years that's called hiring
non-union [ __ ] labor and paying them
non-union what do you do with that extra
twenty dollars that goes in your pocket
that's what kind of yeah that's what
happened you're supposed to get 29 but i
got a [ __ ] spanish dude he'll do it
for nine yeah you know and i put ten of
those guys on the job instead of ten
[ __ ] uh whatever nine guys if you got
nine guys and you're clipping twenty
dollars an hour from nine guys 180 times
nine that's a lot that's how the mafia
made their [ __ ] money and that's what
they try to do with you labor lee went
there for a [ __ ] job and they won't
didn't want to pay him [ __ ] so they're
coming to you saying yeah what about the
editors we're paying them 3 000 now lee
was like they were the worst offer i
ever got up front
so you know they're lying to you they
take oh no we advertising rolling stone
no you [ __ ] don't
no you [ __ ] don't you got some
[ __ ] nicaraguans downtown we print
the [ __ ] things but we make posters
yeah for 200 hours of posting
that's uh you you follow them saying to
you they do let's get bids on posters
well these people say they'll do it for
six these people say they'll do it for
nine these people say they'll do it for
12. let's go with them no go with the
guys for six like that you just save
money right [ __ ] there but no they do
everything they lie to you i'm not doing
that [ __ ] and any marketing that they
would do it's worthless it's worth this
is all the marketing we need there's no
[ __ ] market there's no money they
don't do no marketing they hire a firm
that knows nothing about comedians
and you go on their twitter page they
got 361 followers how good are your
public [ __ ] relations if you got 361
followers i want to hang out with you
i'd rather hang out with somebody with
the hip they got more followers people
feel sorry for you
you're a pr with 20 [ __ ] followers
some chick calling me from denver high
on public i was on the computer hi i'm a
friend or whatever i'm looking for
comedy clients if you'd like to this is
my web page web page was beautiful
puerto ricans women dancing miami vice
you know then i went to the twitter page
22 people what i want to hang out with
you for why i know people got the flu
who got more [ __ ] friends you know
what i'm saying
i know people who got [ __ ] hiv cancer
who got more [ __ ] friends than you 22
people what publicly who the [ __ ] do you
know you know loneliness that's what you
know
[ __ ] these [ __ ] leave oh my
goodness
it was crazy going on stage on saturday
sure it's crazy but you got the balls of
[ __ ] steel that's fine but that's
there there's a great crowd like that
would not have gone as well no well i
told you there were church people so it
would be like stealing every time i'll
go to
out of the [ __ ] thousand people i
show up two hundred them ago did you
bring lisa yeah
they love this [ __ ] guy he goes he's
the
[ __ ] wiggles you could do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants now he's got he's got
him by the ball he's a jew working
backwards
you know what i'm saying he's a jew
hanging out with mussolini who's better
than him
now what what else george perez what do
you got coming on the books i know you
always got movies though cholo
he's got something going on uh you know
what i'm actually doing an autism show
remember that big autism should show up
every [ __ ] year yeah
you do that 22 times a [ __ ] year no
this is my uh fifth year doing it with
them yeah what's the date uh october
21st fullerton fox theater
you're doing a theater yeah no it's it's
cool it's cool we got tom green this
year no [ __ ] yeah tom green sam tripley
we got uh
i can't say we got a special person
hosting i'm not gonna host this here i'm
gonna do a spot and we also got uh
joshua meyerwitz
you know from the store yeah he's uh and
then we got uh keith riza
and we got kate quigley okay so she was
on the podcast good kid yeah yeah yeah i
know i i haven't got to meet her yet but
i've heard good [ __ ] solid solid hard
work i like you you and her are the same
you know always out there
she's always got a bikini on she's a
crazy [ __ ]
but that's what i love about it she's a
crazy [ __ ] but she's not she's not
sucking dicks she's on stage oh that's
good these crazy [ __ ] come out here
put a bikini on they want to suck dick
and try to be fun i'm a comedian yeah
cause you blew three managers all you
got is bad breath you got nothing you
gotta [ __ ] it you gotta write jokes
[ __ ] i haven't had cable for a while i
saw destiny bar on like the commercial
for a show yeah for the show
i like that
yeah yeah yeah he's like in the
commercial yeah dustin don't [ __ ] around
these kids work bro that kid hustles he
was upset because he didn't book a
[ __ ] pile i'm like dustin look at you
you're a handsome [ __ ] just sit
tight
what's up dog
what are you going to harmony talk to me
i have no i wish i could eat i don't
have anything because i was gone she
didn't go you're gonna go food shopping
tonight you're gonna go right to the
sauce gonna get some thai food what are
you gonna do
oh
what's with the
i don't know i'm hungry
all right what are you gonna eat
i know you're gonna go to subway i know
that's what's on your mud
well that's the only healthy thing you
can get you've been thinking subway
since you walked in here i could see i
could sniff
the [ __ ] turkey coming out of your
hip balls and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
beat up turkey
you know [ __ ] case why is it beat up
because it's not cage-free turkey's a
subway but those are [ __ ] turkeys
that get chased by a car all day and
[ __ ] down in some country and [ __ ] is
that part of their process like they
just have like
a ring and they have a little car going
around
that's it and they
like a maverick it's good to see you
george perez i know you're down there i
know you're big with the rap battle
stuff i know that you're all [ __ ] old
geez with the rose battle it's cool man
you know like i barely started going to
the store for like maybe over like a
year now and like from day one to now uh
that's the place to be i'm not putting
all the club down but like i like the
vibe there over there it's
like everyone's trying to get with
everybody it's a dark club and certain
people fit in that club and some people
just really don't yeah you could tell
when a comic walks in there on the way
out if he's ever going to come back i
could tell
like rudy moreno went in there walked
out never came back she made him a
regular mitsy was walking by the [ __ ]
main room rudy was up there doing a
spanish room made him a regular when he
walked off
rudy came one night the set was running
seven minutes late he got in his car and
never came back wow and i knew it
there's just people who
get up in certain situations the store
is not for everybody it's
it's uh it's a combat comedy yeah it's
too real they're right up on top here
the improv is a little bit cleaner
you know
yeah oh my god i just had this quiche
lorraine that was sensational you know
people go to the store they just ate
some of these [ __ ] into the line of
blow you know what i'm saying yeah you
got a laugh factory it's little kids
lorraine yeah
where did you pull that one from that's
who goes to the [ __ ] improv people he
keeps lorraine and
you know
they love whales and you know [ __ ] like
that
they go whale watching the santa monica
i want to stand there and watch a whale
like i want [ __ ] foot fungus in my
[ __ ] you understand me [ __ ] whales do
you think i'll go see that movie about
that guy walking the tightrope across
the building you know what man let me
get a tightrope and have you walk across
from the honda store right through this
window
i'm not going to see that movie that
movie's in 3d which one the movie about
the dude who walks in the tightrope oh
yeah that [ __ ] looks crazy but the
problem is you get high and you go see
that in 3d you're gonna get vertigo
you're gonna get dizzy
you're gonna sit there and go what the
[ __ ] is going on with this [ __ ]
what's the last movie you've seen i i've
seen straight out of compton man
i saw her we just went to see the movie
this week with crazy man black mass oh
okay with uh what's his name about yeah
about what's
no
it was slow i seen it had bad reviews
did they get bad reviews yes they were
saying that you're supposed to like get
oscar nominated or something
no
i thought it was too broad i think they
did a great job but no oscar nomination
but you never know they gave it to the
guy from the hurt locker you know
anybody could win a [ __ ] oscar today
yeah
what was number one movie had to be
black mass uh it was actually it was
maze runner got 30 but then black mask
got 22.
yeah that could be johnny depp's demise
right there what it costs to make it
tells you but he already has another
movie coming out where he plays like
another pirate or something yeah but the
pirates of the caribbean is just [ __ ]
that's a brand that's always gonna make
you know kids go they dress up they stab
each other with
umbrellas get the [ __ ] outta here
you gonna stab me with a [ __ ]
umbrella get a sword you [ __ ]
what happened wait i was trying to find
out how much it caught i don't worry
about it who gives a [ __ ] i'm just
making a point that
you know johnny depp needed a big
[ __ ] movie like this had to be big 22
million
he did a good job he did a good job i
enjoyed the movie i really did i don't
think it's an academy award winner okay
i i i like i like ron livingston where's
the music he's the guy that had like the
beard not the chubby hit man but his
buddy okay he was in office space
oh yeah is it me going to buy a ticket
yeah it's entertainment
you smoke a joint listen it's
entertainment bro okay you know this dip
between being bored or a bad movie and
something entertains you even though
it's slow it's dark and there's this
moment you know but it's a it's a good
story
it's a good story that maybe was told
the wrong way do you agree
i think they
should have focused on something
like they just glazed over like kind of
glazed over his son dying
like he was a like an evil part like he
like didn't go into like
all the murders he used like they like
showed a couple of them but i think
like he was it would have been a cooler
movie if it hadn't been like his entire
life because then
when they do that it's only two hours so
he was [ __ ] ruthless that guy you
know killing women and stuff and i
remember the other day when i was
watching it yeah to be honest with you
there was a minute that i was like i
wanted to be this guy
you know this is the [ __ ] i wanted to
be when i was 20. i thought that that's
what worked i thought that
that was what i had around me those were
the people that were cool the people
that did that stupid [ __ ] you know
for like a minute i was like this could
have been me hanging out with this idiot
well you live by their code and honestly
he starts killing people in front of
your dog killing women what do you do
george
you don't show up to work there they
hunt you down yeah the next day that's
right and with the money he had he puts
a private investigator on your hunch in
california he'll shoot you wherever that
dude
so you got to get a [ __ ] passport and
leave and go halfway around the world i
mean that guy eluded the cops for a long
[ __ ] time [ __ ] when they found him
he still had a half a million [ __ ]
dollars in cash in the wall with guns
and everything
[ __ ] tourists
he had guns in the wall yeah and says
and there was a tourist who rather from
like germany or something how did the
tourists see them they saw they saw it
on cnn they saw like a report on it or
something
and we're like oh i recognize that i
think it was his girlfriend
that's right the girlfriend they fed
cats in the neighborhood
just like hannibal remember how they
they found him in the second movie he
was like in spain or something they got
him with a glass and
when they're looking for you like that
dog it's just a matter of time you gotta
have endless cash
chocolate's the only one to get away
yeah choppa get away chopper somewhere
with 200 [ __ ] surrounding a
building guess what chapel's right here
where would you go
no where would you go and blend not
america
why
listen
if you don't want to be found you got to
be right in front of them
that's how real pimps do it when people
are looking for you you got to be right
in front of them because they're looking
for you out of that circle you're just
not going to go to the same bar you go
to you're not going to go to the same
[ __ ] route you're not going to go to
the same place to get a haircut do you
think that was osama do you think if
they
that's what osama did if that's what no
i'm talking about el chapo ochapo left
[ __ ] mexico where could he go for
america right he went to america so he
went north so he either went to one of
the [ __ ] border states where he could
shave his mustache but they're going to
be looking from there
those little small 30 miles if they
looked at george they know you're not
from around there something's different
so where would he [ __ ] go with all
that money los angeles or chicago
there's tons of [ __ ] mexicans in
chicago he shaves his mustache he dyes
his hair blonde and he gets a die you
know how long it takes him to get a
license and a passport five minutes he's
on his [ __ ] list okay he could do
plastic surgery and shoot the [ __ ]
plastic sturgeon he could do a thousand
[ __ ] things with that type of money
what do you think they don't shoot the
plastic surgeon you're gonna let some
guy know he did plastic surgery on you
that's [ __ ] good luck yeah good
[ __ ] luck imagine getting that phone
call being the plastic surgeon you're
like oh
no you're not gonna get a phone call
it's gonna be a mexican a cousin of a
cousin a cousin of a cousin he's gonna
get the house it's gonna be great you're
not gonna think about it they're gonna
want it done in two days so it gives you
no time to think about it there's no
pre-mep there's no nothing they do crazy
[ __ ] like that they do that [ __ ] in
mexico all the [ __ ] time that's why
you know people go bro my buddy was in
on this business that they're gonna
start a bunch of doctors that have been
like suspended in the united states are
going to go right over the border in
mexico
they're going to take care of you for a
third of what it costs
to do medicine here they're going to oh
great they're going to get buses oh good
they're going to get buses not doctors
who have been suspended like super ebola
my doctors would have been suspended for
killing you on the thing but doctors
that when you passed out they
finger-bang you they're looking for a
second chance
they'll fix your tooth for ten bucks
you're not gonna go see him so what his
fingers know is funny continuation
school doctors and [ __ ] no these are
guys that you know lost license whatever
man what do you think happens what do
you think is your prescriptions for
these [ __ ] medical marijuana licenses
who even gives you prescriptions for
these [ __ ] things yeah but they're
just writing a piece of paper and
thinking about pieces i can't these guys
are abolished we think they're going to
go back and practice medicine when they
write those medical marijuana [ __ ]
licenses lee no
they're guys that are on the way out
their semi retired they don't give a
[ __ ] these russians go to the house and
go how are you doctor
listen we get 75 per license we give you
30. we do 22 licenses a day
when the big thing in michigan when weed
opened up in michigan all the russians
from here left the michigan to open up
medical places because they were getting
three four hundred like it was here ten
years ago medical marijuana license is
250
yeah when i first got my license it was
250 dollars there was no negotiation
nothing you want a license 250. you know
how long the line was when i went i
called that [ __ ] on a monday he
scheduled me for three mondays at two in
the afternoon and when i got there there
was ten [ __ ] luigi's in there in
front of me at 250 a [ __ ] license
you understand me
so this guy might have gotten suspended
or whatever
you know
that's 2500. he was [ __ ] that jewish
church doctor what's the joy what's the
check that the ugly old woman who was
the comedian who died on the electrical
table
what's the [ __ ] name she had like 90
[ __ ] plastic surgery
you know bits like that
check the thousand plastic surgeries
like he's michael jackson's dog
so let me ask you a question is he still
in jail comrade murray
i don't know so conrad murray gets out
of jail he goes to mexico let's say you
need a new eyeball in the united states
they want 22 000 for an eyeball let's
say combat america give it to you for
eight
weeks
you might not wake up
so gives a [ __ ] at least you get the
free my buddy martin perez went to
mexico to get the lap band he said it
cost 30 000 in the united states i don't
know what the [ __ ] it was he says it
cost him 6 000 in mexico
yeah girls go over there to get their
fake asses done in the tits right now
it's like the most yeah that's the most
it's an injection
look at this poor [ __ ] moment what
are you talking about that's what they
do they go that's why i've told you that
my friend got the new kidney remember
they wouldn't give her
celine they wouldn't give her a kidney
for a year she's gonna sign up for a
program she couldn't drink she called
the mexicans they're like drink you can
drink the day up yeah we don't give a
[ __ ] that's how we test the kidney we
give you a shout out tequila to make
sure everything works and [ __ ] you think
they give a [ __ ] about types whether
they match they'll stab a hindu tourist
and give you this [ __ ]
you [ __ ] mexican walking around with
a hindus [ __ ] kidney you always want
to eat that yum yum [ __ ] your feet are
dirty
your feet are dry you're like why the
[ __ ]
my feet always [ __ ] dry i'm puerto
rican why my feet [ __ ] dry and chappy
because you got an indian's kidney in
you
you know something lemon that feet
always dried then [ __ ] those hindus how
do you know because you gotta look at
their feet the judgement man you look at
their toes are they wearing sandals if
yeah they got sandals on they got brown
skin and that toe is grey they haven't
put cream on that foot in 20 [ __ ]
years since they left pakistan
what the [ __ ] you think i'm talking
about here paulie yeah yeah
let me read the ad so you get the [ __ ]
when they're on that note we don't want
it
it's true how [ __ ] up are you on that
star though i'm [ __ ] failing right
now i told you dawg we don't [ __ ] around
here and lead a star and 50 milligrams
200 milligrams what 200 stop [ __ ]
mixing everything that gave me the 50
there's no
fifty one we went through a hundred
stars in las vegas in three things
wow a hundred anarchy edibles
joey fulato the first night that fool
ate three of them he passed out for four
hours he said he ate ice cream 10
[ __ ] times his wife
joe perez ate them me and lee were
eating them like [ __ ] nothing i love
joyful lotto he was walking around like
he was like like you're a hype man he's
like you know why i'm driving a lot you
heard me on the podcast um like all his
stories 100 true
he's the coolest dude he's like like i
was telling you it's weird that you're
like the reserved one
between him and you oh he's loud he's
great he's a good [ __ ] dog
on it.
you know i'm sick and tired of talking
to you about this [ __ ]
shroom tech [ __ ] uh immune that's why
i took three of them before southwest
flight i'm up in [ __ ] dandy please
had to take ten naps because i just won
now don't [ __ ] mad i didn't nap i'm
twice your [ __ ] age i slept five
[ __ ] hours last night i was making
money in the blackjack get the [ __ ] out
of here i didn't even get my 10 percent
yeah i didn't get a final total that
comes to vegas with me oh he was 80 90
200 i don't even nothing trickles down
over here not even a [ __ ] he don't
show up with a cheeseburger nothing what
the [ __ ] sucker
[ __ ] though anyway
back to on it all the supplements they
have a world-class i love this [ __ ] the
hemp protein shake 16 grams of protein
two scoops with a [ __ ] banana you're
brand new a few ice cubes some water
listen i don't give a [ __ ] whether you
believe me or not or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do give it a try yourself
that's true the alpha brains got 100
money-back guarantee and we don't want
the [ __ ] product back who does that
[ __ ] nobody that's a proof testimony
that this [ __ ] will [ __ ] work for you
go to honor.com look at the supplements
look at the great [ __ ] things they
got from the t-booster to the mct oil
they got some stuff that'll put a hem in
your skirt go to on it right now and put
in church and get 10 off your first
order they also have barbells and
kettlebells and weighted vests i can't
do nothing for you on the [ __ ] that
stuff but as far as supplements i get
your ten percent off all right that's
how i wrote number two hitting six i
love these [ __ ] things you see me
smoking them all the time you think i
smoking because i like them you know you
don't you know me i don't like broccoli
i don't eat broccoli for [ __ ] nobody
these ain't [ __ ] bad these are these
things i love them to that that
trademark 1200 [ __ ] guaranteed pups
out of each cigar 1200 whether you get
the cigar or the four cigarettes the
nicotine the e-cigs they got 24 16 8-0
milligrams if you want to quit smoking
what's up tell them they need to call
uh larry so he can be like walking
around because we we were looking for
vapor pens at the casinos they should
have larry and people walking on selling
hate sticks i'll call him first thing in
the morning thank you for interrupting
me with that little tidbit anyway go to
hittiesticks.com right now and press
enter
and get five for five you get a cigar
five for fifty i'm sorry correct me yeah
five for fifty i want you people going
on there with your [ __ ] six dollar
atm card and also they tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself five for 50.
great tastings
24 16 at eight milligrams 86 the proof
is in the puff 1200 guaranteed [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] momo
look at the shape of this poor [ __ ]
guy
you know what
i don't know about you guys
best underwear on the market for me me
undies most comfortable on the way you
ever [ __ ] try they fit [ __ ]
perfectly and they keep the moisture off
your skin i don't care if you jump up
and down for two hours your balls will
always be dry they don't ride up on you
they pull the moisture away from the
skin and they keep you [ __ ] cool you
won't have no shaping the whole thing
i'm not wearing one right now i can
[ __ ] and tell you i feel like i'm
floating i don't have them now i have
them when i work out when i run whatever
the [ __ ] i do stuff like that i want my
balls bouncing around i want to keep the
sweat to a minimum i go with
meundies.com they also make women's
underwear and t-shirts and sweatshirts
they have a great selection of t-shirts
and shorts and these like uh cut
sweatpants but don't believe me go to
myunders.com check out the pics of all
the different styles underwear and for
the girls check out the hot looking boy
shorts they got for you men and women
high quality materials for high quality
materials if you know what i mean the
price i'm glad you asked a fraction of
what typical high-end designer [ __ ]
underwear cost don't believe me do me a
favor go to meundies.com right now look
at the great selection they got you get
20 off your first order 20 off when you
go to meundies.com and right now you're
going to get free shipping in u.s and
canada and the guarantee is you'll be
happy with them trust me like i said if
i'm out of the [ __ ] house slinging
dick i got my me on these on
me on these.com slash joey so go to
myunders.com joey and get 20 off your
first order and free shipping in the
united states and [ __ ] canada you
know you canadians got to keep your nuts
and [ __ ] packed it's getting cold no
let's get to the meat and potatoes of
what i'm talking about here okay
everybody wants to go home smoke a few
joints you're [ __ ] hungry at night
you're gonna eat something bad for you
cut that [ __ ] out go to naturebox.com
right now okay naturebox.com has a great
selection of [ __ ] nutritionists to
prove snacks whether it's the chocolate
yum yums or the or the vanilla almond
granola or the the pacific plantains i
mean listen it's never [ __ ] ending
with them their snacks are delicious
nutritious you'll never go to the
[ __ ] vending machine at work and
they're resealable so you can eat 10
plantains reseal them and put them in
the desk whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do the sesame sticks are to die for i'm
not kidding you people i have these
things at the house i don't give them to
leave [ __ ] him i never get anything
myself my personal favorites are the
chocolate yum yums and the sesame sticks
plain and [ __ ] simple you know what
you're zero chance of getting bored
because they always adding new stuff
whether it's the jalapeno cashews
pumpkin seeds they're always adding new
stuff but do me a favor nature box is
full of flavor without any junk so do me
a favor let's call action here go online
to get your first box at naturebox.com
joey
go online to get your first box at
naturebox.com
joey right now
head to naturebox.com slash joey right
now to unbox a world of taste and
possibilities one last time go to
naturebox.com right now for your first
box of beyond tasty you get five bags
per [ __ ] box man so remember the
smart snack guarantee takes the wrist
out of snack if you don't like a snack
send it back and they'll replace it with
a new one that's what i'm talking about
that's naturebox.com i like to thank on
it me undies naturebox.com
hit e6 and what's the other one
uh
now the life's always there for you like
to thank george perez for coming in
george what's your next comedy date my
brother uh that that uh october 21st
that's the benefit yeah where is it at
fullerton fox theater and is there a web
page they could go that's at uh
fullerton
fullertoncares.com i'll have sam on so
you can promote okay thank you thank you
i'll be in new york city this weekend
but guess what it's sold out 11 45
friday and saturday toledo funny bone
the following weekend october 2nd to the
4th get your tickets right now
i love you guys thank you for supporting
my special i want to thank george perez
for coming up tonight i love this
[ __ ] guy with all my heart follow
george on twitter or facebook
it's a great success story you know he
had problems too and he's out there
making it happen i get emails every week
of people having problems and whatnot
just put your [ __ ] head to it man it
all comes down and you'll be here
laughing you'll be laughing at this 10
years later what's your cop what's your
twitter at george p comedy george p
comedy
are you gonna sit there look at me like
a dunce put on benny murray i'm gonna
drop some [ __ ] music on you tonight
old school cuban music 1950 benny marie
sinatra once walked into a casino in
cuba and heard benny murray and he said
he wanted to shoot him that's how good
this [ __ ] guy's voice was do you want
to play
benny murray como foy a little ballad
for you [ __ ] then you go on
youtube and look at the rest of this
[ __ ]